As some of you know, I turned 50 years
old
earlier this month.
Sadly,
when you cross the half a century
milestone,
your haters
start wondering,
is this guy getting soft in his old age?
Have the years
of threats
and harassment and doxing
finally gotten to him?
Can he still take the heat?
What do you guys think?
Is it time for the D to the I double Z L
E to
sit around doing old people stuff?
Drinking Metamucil?
Playing bingo?
Eating dinner at 4:30 p.m.?
Or does turning 50 years old
mean
playtime's over?
There's only one way to find out.
And that's to stand outside
the Dearborn mosque
on Friday
with a sign that says,
"Why should we believe Muhammad?"
And what better place
to ask that question
than outside the Dearborn mosque?
You hear that? They broadcast their
sermon over the loudspeaker. If they can
proclaim Muhammad over the entire area,
why can't we ask
why we should believe this?
The Quran says we're supposed to believe
it.
Supposed to believe Muhammad.
Says we have to be violently subjugated
if we don't believe it.
Do we at least get to ask why?
Y'all didn't think I came alone, did
you?
Well, so do you have what the Christians
had in the day of Muhammad?
Jesus mentioned that.
Yeah, Jesus mentioned Muhammad. He's
going to come as a prophet.
Go ahead, repeat it. What was your
question? You You tell me.
Bro, what's your point?
REACH OUT TO THESE GUYS, THEY'LL BE
GETTING COOKED.
BRO, YOU'RE GETTING COOKED RIGHT NOW.
ALL ALL THESE GUYS BELIEVE IT WOULD BE
evil and immoral and I agree to have sex
with a 13-year-old. The issue is that
Muhammad had sex
with a 9-year-old. A 9-year-old. A
9-year-old.
Let the guy have some space, bro.
Better back up.
Listen, may God guide us all to the
right path. That's all I say, man. You
know, God Allah is the most merciful.
So, hopefully you repent.
How are you doing? What's your name?
I'm not going to argue with you while
I'm eating dinner.
He is seeing and now listen to
It's okay. We can have a respectful
dialogue.
These guys can have a respectful
dialogue. I've never seen you but these
clowns are here. These two are Hey, you
can have a respectful dialogue.
You ran away from our church. Who keeps
running? I'VE NEVER RUN AWAY.
I HEREBY agree to have a debate with
Sheikh Uthman ibn Farooq in this mosque
or anywhere else on the planet. He will
not.
>> NOT WANT TO
I KNOW HE WON'T. He won't He won't He
runs from God logic.
Let's have a conversation.
He ran from me. He ran from me.
Tell him yeah, we saw the video where he
ran. He didn't come out the mosque.
Everywhere Everywhere we go
no one wants to have a debate but they
all say
everyone's running from Sheikh Uthman.
It's like
what kind of fantasy land
do people live in?
It's weird.
Look, my sign's right here.
What do you want? You want to come in?
You can't, bro. You can't be touching
girls and stuff. Get out of here. Like a
prophet. Get out of here, bro. My
prophet if he touched a girl no one
follow him but you probably would if he
did. BUT YOU A CLOWN, DUDE.
HIT ME 133. MUHAMMAD HAD SEX WITH A
9-YEAR-OLD.
A 9-year-old.
Hey, if you guys was sincere you'd be a
Muslim. Your heart would be open.
God designed this.
Go, bro.
Get out of here. You're lost.
I want
We want you to experience the truth,
brother. That's Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ loves you. He He said he's
the hall monitor. This guy right here in
the white. And they don't want to have a
conversation. Yeah.
Yeah, they'll come blow the horn.
They'll talk to us from our cars.
They'll call us cowards, call us nerds,
clowns, whatever they want to call us.
Hey, listen.
It happened to Christ.
It happened to Christ. He was spat on,
hated, mocked.
But he loved them enough to to come and
give them a message. So that's what
we're here to do today.
We're going to give these people a
message.
So you're you're welcome to like call us
and
if the number is here, okay? Okay. It's
here
we can have like
dialogue and
I would love to. And we can and we can
we can get you inside the mall. Okay.
Yeah. So we we receive like
so many visitors from churches, from
grand rabbis, from everywhere. They come
and give them a tour. So we're we are
all brothers, right?
We have the same God.
Absolutely. [laughter]
Look, I mean I got two eyes, you got two
eyes. I got no ears. So we are all the
same. So I'm going to give you this. So
this is the Quran in English. You can
read it. Which translation is that? So
this is this is Quran in English.
Yeah. Awesome. Hey, no.
No, no.
No, no, no. I like the way he knew what
it was.
And this is like uh Yeah, I have I have
a Sahih Muslim.
>> Yeah, so we You You guys shouldn't be
afraid. You should
You guys are afraid. That's what it is.
We're not afraid of Islam. You guys are
afraid of Islam.
You don't look like it, but inside your
hearts you GUYS ARE AFRAID.
WE LIKE HOW THIS GUY is talking more. I
I love you. I love you for the SAKE OF
GOD. RIGHT, RIGHT. BUT THIS GUY'S got a
good smile. I got to go over to work,
but I want to say one MORE LAST THING.
I WANT TO SAY ONE MORE LAST THING.
In Islam, it says you can take 70 people
with you, whoever you choose.
To heaven? I'm going
>> [laughter]
>> I'm going to look at you one more time,
each one of you. This one the day of
judgement, I'm going to pick you guys
all to come with me because if you
don't, you're going to another side.
Okay. So, hey, we got to agree to
disagree, y'all.
All All prophets came from the same God,
okay? All prophets, like from Abraham to
Noah, to Moses
to Jesus, you know? So, they came and
they came with messages and then
the the books that they came with,
unfortunately, were distorted, like they
were changed, you know? So, Prophet
Muhammad came as the last one, as the
last prophet to complete the message of
all prophets, okay? And they came with
Quran, which I'm going to give you
today, the Quran. And the Quran, you
know, it says the truth thing and no
prophet came after Prophet Muhammad. So,
he's the last prophet and if you follow
Prophet Muhammad, you're following Jesus
as well. We love Jesus, he's our
prophet. We believe him as a prophet,
okay? Peace upon him. So, that's why we
need to believe in Muhammad
because, you know, he's the last message
and he completes whatever all other
prophets came with, you know, same
message from God. It's the message of
Islam. So, I'm going to give you this
book, you read it and then there is a
number here, you're welcome to call us
and we can have like a better time,
we'll get you in the inside of the
mosque and we'll give you a tour and we
can talk more. How about that?
Really?
How many you got? Can I get one of
those? Yes, one for me. Thank you. Just
be careful. God bless you guys. Now, God
Logic had the brilliant idea of bringing
stands for his sign. I figured I'd just
hold mine up.
I don't know if I need to do a
lot of shoulder workouts, but this gets
tiring real real quick, like
Yo, what's What's AP? Hey, man, what's
up? What's going down? Nothing. Nothing
is happening. How was it? Any Anybody
brave enough to come and argue? There
were lots of Muslims who were willing to
come up and have a discussion, but
there's like a a hall monitor type who
goes around telling them don't uh don't
engage, which is weird. Which is weird.
But do you guys need any water or
anything? I just want to say this. Um
you know, um we're blessed and we're
very fortunate to be living in the
United States and we are able to
practice our religion how we'd like. And
we
are right.
Oh, of course. Yeah, no, of course. And
uh what I what I just wanted to come
over here and tell you guys is I wish
you guys a a good Friday. Happy Friday,
you know, and
a blessed life and uh there's nothing
between us,
We really can't make something small so
big between us. At the end of the day,
you know, we're all human We're all
humans. We all breathe. We all
We all walk walk the same. Some of us
have disabilities and doesn't work out,
but what I'm trying to say is that you
have the right to believe in whatever
you believe in as long as you don't
insult people or flick me or flick me, I
shall not do the same. And the one thing
I will say is that um
uh verse from the Bible, um thou shall
love thy neighbor.
That's all I have to say. Yeah.
So, you think if you go high enough, you
are reaching
>> Yeah, then jail.
What is it?
I have one at the house, actually. I
appreciate it.
I'll take it from you. It's no problem.
Nothing wrong with that. Nothing wrong
with seeking a little bit of knowledge
and you know, make seeing you know, you
being a Christian or Catholic or
whatever it may be, I'm not going to
walk up to you and tell you you're
wrong.
Straightforward. You have the right to
do whatever you want in life. We will
just relay the message to you and then
hopefully we can all leave off on a good
basis with a good taste in our mouth and
uh not really walk away with any hatred
or any animosity towards each other. So,
first and foremost, you know, I just
want to wish you guys a happy Friday, a
good Friday. God bless you guys in your
life and you and your families. Um
we wish nothing but the best for
everybody regardless of whatever
religion, race you are, so. And as I
said, you know, I'm I'm not I'm not
educated 100% fully in the Quran. As I
said, I'm studying every day and I want
to learn more and more. I mean, I'm not
perfect. I'm not a scholar.
So, anything in regards to the Quran or
any questions you guys may have or
anything, you know, I would feel more I
would feel more comfortable, you know,
passing it on to a Imam or a scholar.
You guys have a wonderful day. God bless
you guys. God bless you all.
Stop saying that it seems like they have
a system. There ain't no system, bro.
Everybody is a free world, bro. We do
whatever the [__] we want, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> All right, well We do whatever the [__]
we want.
>> an accusation or anything actually I
mean, it's a good thing that you guys
have figured it out because
problematic people in every camp and
some problematic people will be very
very
fired up fired up
fired up to come and into discuss it.
You said you want to advise to the right
path. What's the right path?
That That when we die it's too late. I
want to know the answer now. You can
talk to the Imam. I don't got like too
too much uh knowledge, but I know what's
right and I'm happy that God placed me
in the right place.
>> Well, we say Islam is false.
So, can I say I love Allah? I love
Muhammad, but I believe Allah is a false
god and Muhammad is a false prophet or
is that not love?
What?
Jesus and Muhammad are both a prophet.
What's wrong with that?
>> Uh Jesus is God. Muhammad is a false
prophet. Is that loving for me to say? I
think it's actually loving for me to say
towards you because I want you to know
truth, but I don't think it's loving
towards Muhammad.
Jesus even appeared to people before his
incarnation. Are you aware of that?
People had conversations with Jesus
before he incarnated. Are you aware of
those?
And even then he was still Yahweh.
The The scribes wrote him as Yahweh as
well. This Sunday you'll come to church
with us? What if I come to your church
and do this? Yeah, sure. We'd be happy
to even let you use our uh microphones
and our speaker in front of the church.
Would you be willing to do that for us?
I'm not wasting my time doing that.
Well, I thought you just said you were
going to. I I didn't I said, "What if
What if" Oh, okay. Okay. Well, would you
be willing to?
I would not be willing I would not be
willing Why would that be a waste of
time? Cuz that would be a waste of time.
You think it's a waste of time to care
about people's hearts and souls? This is
your eternity at stake. This is our
eternity at stake, right? Can you prove
it to me so I can believe in Jesus as a
god and not as a prophet?
>> Oh, sure. Yeah. So, what would you count
as proof?
If I find Jesus claiming to be God,
would you count that as proof?
I want to ask you a question. Well, hold
on. You just asked me a question. I'm
trying to figure out how to answer your
question.
>> to ask you a question. Okay, what's your
next question?
>> Jesus is God, right?
>> Yes, Jesus is God.
>> who came before, Jesus or Abraham? Uh
Jesus came before Abraham. Before
Abraham was I am.
That's what Jesus said.
Say that again. Jesus said, "Before
Abraham was I am." Action upon action.
Dearborn has been crazy so far, man. We
had the calm Muslims. We had the
aggressive Muslims. We had the insulting
Muslims. We had people talking "It's my
It's my It's my Leave him alone, you
know." Trying to get them to
uh stop talking to us, but man, overall,
we've been having a couple good
conversations. Still got good
conversations. Everybody's witnessing,
planting seeds. It's really It's really
fun, man. I don't know where I've been
all my life. I should have been coming
out here to Ohio and Dearborn, Michigan.
This is where This is where it's at.
This is where it's at.
Yeah.
All right, here with my main man, Life.
How things
go for you? Look, so
what happened was what I expected, okay?
50/50. Foolery and curious people. So, I
always love that. And also, too, if we
scoot over here to the
right a little bit, we have the police
here, and I'm glad that they sat here
and didn't bother us, but just waited to
see if something happened which nothing
did not cuz David told me prior
a
officer came and took their IDs and got
their information and then Yeah, that
that was Yeah, that was years ago. That
was years ago. That was over a decade
ago. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it was not a good
experience. So, I'm glad that we were
actually able to have discussions as my
boy word right here
is having a discussion right now and
it's just it's exactly what I expected.
Foolery and curious people and so and
also nice people do came out give us
some ice cold water really in the clutch
and
I mean that's that's kind of what you
get. People are passionate about their
religion and they're going to come out
and they're going to be
some of them are going to be angry, some
of them are going to be cool and some of
them are going to come out and say
foolishness like logic why are you
running from Sheikh Uthman and then we
had to get away from those jokers and
get the good people that come up. So, I
think it's a good experience. I like it.
50/50 for me. You know, we're we're
we're fine with
whatever types come at us. People want
to have a nice conversation, we're happy
to have a nice conversation. Want to get
more aggressive, we're totally fine with
that. I actually have a bunch of footage
that
I'm not going to use because we had and
a discussion like kids would come up and
get in the camera and I kind of I kind
of don't like posting any sort of
footage with with little kids in there
and stuff. So,
but yeah, we can we can say at least the
leaders and so on seem pretty cool.
>> Yeah. So, AP
What do you think about heading to
Dearborn Mosque? Were you terrified?
I was trembling. I actually
I had to change my underwear because I
peed my pants on the way here. Yeah, so
he was massively delayed for repeatedly
having to change his drawers and his
pants. But what do you think after uh
How did things went?
I think it was very nice. I think it
went very well. Um
there was a system in place and I said
when I when I earlier pointed out that
there was a system in place. Some guy
became very There clearly was. There
clearly was. But there was clearly a
system in place. So,
we had we had of course
you know certain people who came up and
who wanted to aggressively
talk to us and aggressively have
discussions, but there were others here
that blocked them off and said, "Hey,
move on. Move on. Get out of Get out of
here." They clearly have something in
place where certain people are basically
in charge of who should be and should
not be talking to
provocateurs like us. And the very nice
ones would come and talk to us and give
us these little things like a Quran.
Despite that, some people over there,
when not over here, did comment
aggressively talk to us.
>> No, that happened over there, too. Yeah.
Yeah. Some people shouted, said, "Hey,
why don't you go to a Jewish
neighborhood?" And I was like, "Well, we
could."
Actually, they do.
Yeah.
But yeah, we we had we had interesting
discussions.
Certain people Several people came here
and
tried to have very very long
conversations. I think one of those over
there
lasted for over half an hour and it was
it was basically The argument was
basically about how they love Jesus more
than Christians love Jesus.
And so, we pointed out that that is
simply not true because the we know that
the real Jesus made certain claims about
himself, such as that he claimed that
he's God.
He claimed that he's the son of God. He
made these claims. We know We know what
his immediate followers believed. So, if
a Muslim comes and says we love Jesus,
but he doesn't believe that Jesus is
God, he doesn't believe that Jesus is
the son of God, then that Muslim
believes that Jesus lied or that Jesus
made false claims about himself, that he
claimed to be something that he is not.
You can't believe that Jesus lied about
himself, that he made such grandiose,
such such messed up,
you know, lies about false claims about
himself, and then also say, "Hey, we
love him more than you do." No, we we we
believe him. We believe in everything
that he said, right? Christians believe
in everything that he said, which is why
we love him. Or which which is why our
love is quite evident, let's say.
They don't. So, we pointed this out and
the discussion then moved on to what
it's illogical. How is Jesus How is
Jesus God, but he was born after after
Abraham and
and all that. So, you know, we did have
lengthy discussions about
the incarnation, Jesus becoming
God taking on flesh and things like
that.
It was okay. It was okay. It was good. I
think there were some fruitful
discussions here. And we want for every
Muslim to leave Islam and to become a
Christian.
Or you know, if you can't make that step
yet, you can become something else and
then you can become a Christian. Or we
can force you to become a Christian
later on.
But
we care about the Muslims themselves and
we have respect and love for them. My
some of my favorite people out there are
ex-Muslims.
I love the Muslims and I want them to
leave Islam
for their own good,
for my good, primarily for the good of
all.
And that's what we are here to do. So,
stay away from Islam, boy.
Smart.
You won't hear me say this a lot
in life,
given some past experiences here, but
shout out
to the Dearborn Police Department.
They showed up, couple cars. There's
only one left. That's one in the
background. Um
but they stayed off in the distance and
they were just monitoring in case
anything happened and that's exactly
what police should be doing. They didn't
interfere. They didn't stop us.
They didn't lock anybody up. So,
it's better than it was years ago.
All right, here with L. We're packing it
up. You were on
a microphone.
And
frequently you had more people coming up
to you than uh God logic down on the
other end. So, we're thinking it's
either because you're a woman or
because uh you had a mic and more people
could hear you. But, uh what's your uh
what's your thoughts on today? Yeah, it
was very interesting. We had some very
good conversations with people. Lots of
claims were made that were blatantly
false and we were able to correct some
of those. Hopefully, we'll be able to
continue to correct some of those as we
did get some contact information, but I
did find it shocking how few Muslims
were actually willing to engage on the
microphone. I've done this in the past
many times and had conversations with
Muslims on the microphone. They're
typically happy to proclaim their views
for the world to see, but in this case
they wanted to stay off the mic. So, I
did find that strange, but hopefully it
was all for the best and I'm glad that
we had the conversations we did today.
Lots of Muslims were uh committing shirk
or apostasy without really realizing it,
but uh you know, that tends to happen in
Islam. It's kind of something you're
forced into when you follow it in part
cuz you can't follow it in whole. All
right, here with Eric. Eric, you were
around the corner and you were having a
conversation over there. Uh what were
you guys talking about? Well, we were
covering um Quran 98:6 which talks about
all Jews and Christians being the worst
of creatures. And I was asking him why I
am called the worst of creatures in the
Quran. On top of that I was asking him
why in Sahih Muslim then Jews and
Christians are paying for the sins of
Muslims on the day of resurrection and
going to hell for their sins.
And when you bring up these passages,
whether from the Quran or the Hadith,
did they have any clue what you're
talking about? Absolutely not. In fact,
I've had multiple times that Muslims
have called me liar over just reading
Quran 98:6 to them because they have no
clue. In this case, they didn't, but he
still had no clue about either Quran
98:6 or
the Hadith itself. They just had no clue
of either of them.
And so, it's basically the Quran and
Hadith
are filled with all kinds of things that
completely contradict what Muslims
believe about Islam
and their leaders keep this stuff from
them.
So, they're only going to hear the truth
about their own religion
if we tell them.
Right here with the Dizzel over here in
Dearborn, the the Eliminator. Finally
met him in person, man. Like dude is
awesome. Been watching his content
forever.
Uh I think we made a bit of an impact.
We got a couple of guys to talk to. We
got a couple of good uh conversations.
David, you know, he's uh
always funny, always bright. And uh
Hey, I'm glad to just be here
with in the presence of David Wood
and AP. And uh man, y'all don't know,
man. I I I started off watching all
these guys.
And for me to actually be here
participating with them in something
this big, I'm just grateful, highly
favored by by God and Jesus and
I feel like I'm where I needed to be. I
found a home with these guys in God
Logic and
uh
many more to come. Many more to come.
I'm just getting started. Yeah, man. So,
we came out here. We planted seeds. You
know, there's some good Christian
dialogue. Uh met some opposition, but we
also got some good conversations though.
Saddest part is the ignorance of the
Muslims that we spoke to today. Um
they
I just we just had a conversation with a
brother who really really is holding on
to Muhammad. Uh defending child marriage
and all these kind of things. Making all
kinds of excuses. And that's when it
gets That's when it gets sad, you know,
because of the brainwashing. And so, but
we're We're to keep trying. This is why
we're doing what we're doing. To plant
seeds. We got a
a lot of people to listen
and and a lot of thought-provoking
questions were were given to the Muslims
today. So, now they'll they'll never
forget today. That's for sure. They'll
never forget today.
Well, fun trip here.
No one got violence. So,
that's cool.
There was kind of a mixture of
more aggressive Muslims and then
really nice Muslims and you know, that's
that's pretty common. There are people
who are aggressive and there are people
who are really nice.
When the aggressive ones would start to
have a discussion, there were people who
were kind of shooing them off and saying
don't engage with these guys. So,
that's kind of sad because
we're fine we're fine with people, you
know, defending what they believe
aggressively. We're not fine if you get
violent and so on, but if people want to
argue and so on, that's cool, but
lots of the guys who actually would
stand there and talk were
very calm very nice. They were saying we
could come back and take a tour of the
mosque. So,
the leaders it sounds like the leaders
here and lots of the people here are
very nice, very cool.
There are some hotheads. That's true in
lots of places. That's not really a
problem.
But,
cool day. Cool day. Cool day.
This is the third time he's calling us
out about Easter, bro. Oh, he is? He
said
the OG is calling us out about Easter.
Easter? Easter.
I was just saying I was saying where is
Mike Jones when you need him? 24 hours
is a day is a day is a day. That's what
I said. But, when I said I worked three
days, you knew you knew I still knew I
did not work three That's how that's how
we count a quarter day.
>> that argument.